body camera video shows the moments
leading up to a deadly officer-involved
shooting in California moments after a
suspect punched a sheriff's deputy in
the face I'm gonna fuck your ass up okay
you better step back right I said get
the fuck out of here now step back Grace
I'm gonna fight I'm gonna fight
the Los Angeles
Sheriff's Department released the body
camera video this week stemming from an
incident on January 11th officials say a
9-1-1 call came in for a transient at a
Santa Clarita Mall
can help you
hello
um calling from the with Olympia Mall
just calling because we basically have
this transient who was the recording
issues at first but we found him
sleeping in front of these we tried
talking to him I know you know expert
property you can't sleep here but he
does not want to leave at all that he
just basically we won't start a flight
whenever we go up to him try to make
them leave the caller can be heard on a
recording of the 9-1-1 call asking for
sheriff's deputies to intervene they
want us to come there and trespass them
yeah basically like just to come down
here and just make them leave property
because whenever we try to talk to him
he just get to The Irate and just
basically just says the only way I'm
gonna get out of here because I put one
of you in the Chokehold stuff like that
just before 11 o'clock that night a
female Los Angeles County Sheriff's
deputy arrives to the scene surveillance
video shows her approach the suspect
later identified as 50 year old
Christopher Lee Mercurio the first 35
seconds of her body camera video do not
have audio this is the first thing we
hear from her exchange with Mercurio so
look I'm just coming over because the
security for the mall yeah I'm not gonna
move at all I will actually kill
everything that comes here okay well we
don't want that I don't care that's what
I'm okay after this the sheriff's deputy
attempts to de-escalate the situation as
Mercurio continues to make threats okay
look I'm just trying to talk to you okay
okay I'm gonna sleep right here so you
can do what you want to do okay either
protecting the fan or I'm gonna destroy
your human being
I understand I understand but why are
you coming at me like that well I'm just
letting you know and I'm just letting
you know too okay don't tell me what to
do at all I'm not letting you know I'm
not telling you what to do okay I'm just
letting you know what security has
advice is I am security for the whole
country okay the video goes on to show
the deputy repeatedly asked Mercurio to
step back but he does not you want Iran
and China to bust your nut or what no
not at all well listen to me did I say
that just listen no I'm telling you
right now listen no I'm no we're not
doing you know what hey you better step
back dude step back he continues to
approach and punches the sheriff's
deputy in her face I'm gonna fuck your
ass up okay you better step back right I
said get the fuck out of here now step
back
they're fine get off me that's when the
sheriff's deputy pulls out her weapon
and threatens to shoot Mercurio if he
does not back away when he refuses she
opens fire if you come any closer I'm
gonna shoot you I'm going to shoot you
dude
get up stop
I'm gonna hear you dude the sheriff's
deputy fires two shots at Mercurio he
then walks to the corner area of the
mall
don't responding
shots fired shots fired
after the sheriff's deputy makes a shots
fired call a second Deputy arrives on
the scene
when asked about Mercurio's weapon the
sheriff's deputy says he doesn't have
one does he have a gun
the second sheriff's deputy then begins
to give Mercurio Medical Aid after that
the Los Angeles Fire Department arrives
and takes him to a nearby hospital where
he's later pronounced dead the name of
the Deputy involved in the shooting has
not yet been released publicly right now
the shooting is still under
investigation by the California
Department of Justice and upon
completion will be turned over to the
Attorney General's office reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie